people I'm David thorburn director of
the MIT Communications Forum this I
think may be go will probably go down in
my uh memory banks as my favorite Forum
because uh Our Guest today is an old
friend of mine and the individual who I
think in my own experience in the 20
years he was at MIT had the largest
impact on the institution of any
colleague I've known in the humanities
Henry Jenkins is the Provost professor
of communication journalism and
cinematic Arts at the University of
Southern
California he he arrived at USC in 2009
after 20 years at
MIT where among other things he was the
founding director of the comparative
media studies program and held the uh
endowed chair the Peter deflores
professor of humanities
chair uh he's the author or editor of at
least 12 books the number may have
changed uh uh in the last uh six months
um because Henry is one of the most
prolific writers uh uh in media studies
as well as an immensely influential
teacher and blogger
um some of his tit some of the titles of
his books can give you some sense of the
reach and impact of his work convergence
culture you can hear in the titles of
his books the themes that have organized
media study over the last decade or more
uh another of his titles uh an earlier
book an immensely influential book
really giving rise to the whole area of
fan studies of fan culture uh the title
of the book is textual poaches
television fans and participatory
culture um
um it's almost impossible to to
overemphasize the impact that Henry's
work has had on media studies in the
United States over the last 25 years
years uh and one of the things I hope to
do in our conversation today is talk
about some of the leading themes in his
work as well as some of the things that
uh some things that have to do with his
own biography where to try to figure out
where this remarkable man came from in
some respects so uh uh The Forum will
follow it our our usual pattern Henry
and I will talk for about 40 minutes or
45 minutes and then we'll turn it over
to the audience for uh I hope even more
intense and and and uh interesting
conversation uh uh Henry's work is so
diverse and covers so many different
territories that I count on the audience
to cover gaps that don't come up in our
general
conversation um Henry maybe we couldn't
start by uh asking you to U I'd like to
start by asking you to think back and
I'm motivated here by this by by a a
what is in my memory one of your most
beautiful pieces of writing uh the
commemorative obituary you wrote for
your mother and in the course of reading
that I came to a much clearer
understanding of how your early life
your childhood and your and uh before
you and your your your years in in in in
high school uh already had uh showed
qualities that defined the work that
came later and I wonder if You' talk a
bit about that yeah sure it's really
difficult to know where to start and
talking about one's family uh one place
to start would be to think about
something that's hanging in the wall of
my office at USC that was not hanging in
my wall here but there's a picture of
pogo Walt Kelly's comic strip character
and this was a picture that had hung on
my father's office at Georgia Tech when
he was a undergraduate student there in
the 1950s it was drawn by my mother who
carefully recreated it from Walt Kelly's
original artwork and she had stuffed it
away way in the Attic someplace to for a
very long period of time and after they
passed away I found it along with a
photograph of my father's study and
realized that this had been there that
far back so I took it and hung it on the
wall of my office at USC in many ways
remind you of where I came from and one
part of that is of course
Georgia uh and you know Walt Kelly's
really interesting because he's from
Connecticut he never lived in Georgia
yet he was accepted by Georgians in the
midst of a period of great Regional
divide as someone who spoke in the voice
of Georgia who captured something about
the culture of the South uh and that
that work had always spoken to me and my
father's well-worn copy of the paperback
versions of pogo were very very
important to me growing up and a me his
point of connection for me to my father
who was in many ways a very practical
man he went to Georgia Tech he was
trained as an architect he ran a
construction company he had a very
applied sense of the universe and I
remember at one point he he came to me
and we were traveling together he
pointed to a building a church that he
had built in his construction company
and said see that that will still be
here in 20 years so what are you putting
your name on that will still be here in
20 years well last year the 20th
anniversary copy of txol poachers came
out and I feel a certain sense of Pride
that as Victor Hugo said holding the
book this will be that right uh but the
sense of a continuity of is there and a
way of responding to my father's but my
mother also was an artist right and she
never would have called herself that she
was always doing craft she was always
making things but the fact that she was
well able to draw Pogo in such a
convincing way uh and create something
that I still value as a as a work of art
to the present day says something about
my mother my mother was also a clown uh
she did clowning for charity and I grew
up seeing my mother as a clown there's a
portrait that I still have in my living
room room um that her best friend
painted of her and her clown Garb which
is the way I will always remember my
mother so when I was on the donu show
years ago and got beaten up trying to
defend violent video games and called my
mother in the phone rather sheepishly
because it had been a humiliating
process and she looked she her line to
me was you forgot to make them
laugh and it was and more importantly I
forgot to laugh myself in the process
and so that's the advice from my mother
that always remember um so that that
picture in some way embodies an awful
lot about them they were both very
active in the church the Baptist Church
um and part of their philosophy always
was that if someone in your community
asked for your help and you can give it
you're morally and ethically obligated
to do so and that's a philosophy that I
have lived through lived with for most
of my life the challenge is they were
doing it in a small local Comm
congregation and I do it in an age of
global internet and so the demands the
potential of what your community is
who's asking for help how much help can
you possibly process in a day is is
shift pretty profoundly but there is a
sense to me that when I think about the
choices I make as a professional there
AR each governed by that commitment to
community to service to trying to give
yourself over to other people and if you
can help someone you're an obligation to
do it it's not it's not uh do I have the
time do I have the inclination it really
is your do you have a commitment and
that was very important but my father
and mother never really got the media
studies side of this um but when I was
about to go off to grad school my
grandfather pulled me aside and took me
into his tool shed and he had which is
full of wooden crosses he'd made and
metal he'd done he was a sheep metal
worker uh and he he said I wanted to
give you this and he gave me a check not
a significant amount of money but enough
money that meant something for him who
was living on his retirement funds and
and so forth and he's recalled The
Experience he had of leaving the farm in
rural Georgia going off to World War I
and making the decision when he came
back when everyone in the family
expected him to return to the farm to
move to Atlanta to be part of the city
for him that was the connection he made
to me going off to graduate school and
he on a deep in some levels understood
more deeply than anyone else the choice
I was making to leave the South and go
to school and study something that no
one around no one in my family
understood what possibly how you could
possibly imagine you could make a living
studying popular culture and graduate
school and going off with a PD PhD
someplace is my father would say one of
those one of those doctors who can't do
you any good uh and that that sense of
going off to was with my grandfather
that connected to my grandfather so when
I get to grad school one of the first
things that I read that was really
deeply significant to me was rayan
Williams essay culture is ordinary where
Williams is describing his journey from
the the farm country from the rural
Hinterland from workingclass background
into Elite institutions and the choices
that he made and so forth and what I
admire most about that essay are first
of all the ways in which Williams
refuses to forget where he came from
that Williams responds to the experience
of those people whose taste May differ
from his posteducation whose background
and goals differ from his but he feels
still feels a connection to and a deep
respect for the ordinariness of culture
the ordinariness of political voice the
importance of respecting those voices
and bringing them into the conversation
and secondly his refusal to accept
theories that clash with his own lived
experience right there are places in
that essay where rayan Williams just
draws a line and says that's what I'm
being taught in the school but it can't
it doesn't make sense in relation to the
life I've lived the people I've known
the conversations I've participated in
and for me the first phases of my
graduate career were were very much like
that that I was coming into grad school
at a moment where the theory was all
about subject positioning and the
powerlessness of the audience and so
forth and I was looking for a way that
respected the fan communities I'd been
part of in high school the the kinds of
cultural remix practices that i' seen in
my own family whether it's my mother
copying a picture of a comic strip and
making it something personal that she
gives to my father whether it's my
grandmother who was a remix artist
because she was a quilter and appalache
that those kinds of experiences had to
be respected by the theories that were
there and I kept questing found cultural
studies found John Fisk found Raymond
Williams and that gave me a language to
talk about some of the things in my
background that I had not couldn't talk
about in the theoretical vocabulary that
was dominating media studies in the late
70s early 80s so there's
hardly a part of popular culture on
which Henry has not written
wonderfully in some sense I just from my
own memory of things of his that I've
read do you remember your essay on
wrestling of of course I'm not quite
that old and I'm forgetting my essays
yet but you've written so much I'm not
sure you can remember it all U um so
wrestling children's Children's culture
Henry has written widely about
children's culture and of course at the
center of his work especially in the
early part of his career were were these
theories of of of fan appropriation and
maybe we should talk a little bit more
about that Henry because it was such a
central aspect of the early part of your
career and continues in some sense to be
part of your perspective on media
culture yeah I mean I had been as I
write in the beginning of textual
poachers I was a fan well before I was
an academic indeed being passionate
about media was what drove me into
studying it in the first place so I the
only language I have to write about
popular culture is from the inside and I
don't in fact the nature of popular
culture is it creates intimacy it
creates emotional intensity academics
who try to write about popular culture
from the outside I think Miss so much
about the phenomenon you have to write
within its thrw you have to write in
relation to its place and our everyday
life to me to fully capture why popular
culture matters what's the stakes are in
popular culture and pop popular politics
so beginning to write about fans was a
natural outgrowth of that um as I said
the the the book work I wrote to ex
poachers is now 20 years old that's the
book where I coined the phrase
participatory culture and began to try
to figure out what that phrase meant I
still struggle with the phrase It's you
know every year I discover that more
deep questions to ask about whether
that's an adequate way to describe
what's what's going on and partially
it's because the phrase participation
cuts across so many different
disciplines that I was drawing at that
moment almost entirely on a cultural
studies media studies trajectory the
same moment in time there was a lot of
resurgence of interest in participatory
politics and political philosophy has
dealt very deeply in that over there was
a huge tradition and educational theory
whether we're you know we're talking
about Thomas dwey or Palo FR or Seymour
papert who was a huge influence on me
when I arrived at MIT those all have
theories of participation John Jean love
um we are now at a point where we have
to bring the fan study strand into
dialogue with those other traditions and
so fans continue to influence and inform
my work the last few years I've really
been trying to create dialogues across
some of these different Traditions so I
did a piece for convergence last year
where I exchange with niik carpentera
who's a european-based political
philosopher who's thought deeply about
participation and it really is trying to
explore how cultural theories of
participation and political theories of
participation can learn from each other
other Nick cry and I just edited a Ser a
series that'll run an international
Journal of communication that brings
together about 20 Scholars across a
range of different disciplines talking
through what we mean by participation
and it'll be divided into uh creativity
uh politics
Labor uh education knowledge and
learning and Technologies and platforms
and we'll run over the next six months
once one a month uh online
really rich dialogue that has emerged
from critical theorist more more
emancipatory theorist talking about what
we mean for it but for me that my point
of entry into that was was through
fandom uh and I think it's still a very
powerful idea the present time I'm
really applying those ideas to thinking
about participatory politics and youth
movements mostly in the United States
but around the world where people are
drawing on the language of popular
culture and the practices of
participatory culture to try to make
change um Henry one one thing I'd like
to ask you about is press you harder on
we mentioned this earlier when we were
planning this this conversation uh is
there's a way in which a kind of a
politically radical critique of your
position would say something like look
all this talk about particip
participation is a kind of uh
mystification because the fact is what
these fans are dealing with has been
handed to them by the corporate culture
it's not as if writing uh a new version
of Star Trek is as imaginative as
creating your own world how do you
answer that complaint well there's a
there's a bunch of assumptions built
into that I mean I think I think history
tells us that people build on the
culture that's around them that we draw
on the resources which are there so we
could describe the painters of the
Renaissance As derivative because all of
their stories come from the Bible by
that same logic right they're painting
all this endless madonas and children
and they're not making up anything new
and any new stories emerging from that
yet we would say the measure of that is
what why it was meaningful to them why
it's meaningful to the culture the
Aesthetics they brought to bear on it so
the the fact it's derivative to me is
not the crucial question the fact that
they are bound up with a set of
categories reproduced by a
commercialized industry is more
troubling to me right and and this
question is what we we can only build
those things our raw materials allow us
to
construct that those materials bring
constraints for them seems important and
I've always talked about fandom as a
Miss as a mixture of Fascination and
frustration there is a tendency to think
for people to assume what I'm saying is
all resistance all the time that people
are breaking out of Pop Culture that
they're simply masters of their own
universe and that's not what I'm arguing
although that's the radical side of what
I'm arguing I am arguing that they're
not totally constrained contained
manipulated by media that they are
making choices in relation to it and I
think those choices are collective
rather than individual which is why
phandom as a kind of social formation is
very interesting to me it's a space
where we form Collective opinions Forge
Collective myths engage with a Civic
imagination that that part is very very
important to me but they are working
with a culture that has been patriarchal
homophobic you know colonialist um all
we can say all kinds of negative things
about the values of that culture they
push and pull at it but they are the
consumate negotiated readers right we
are building on a mythology whose
elements we don't fully understand or
fully engage with the challenge fandom's
facing right now has to do with race
right I think fandom has been really
fairly Progressive in the politics of
gender and sexuality through the years I
think it has been far less so in the
politics of race and and many and
phandom would agree with that there have
been heated debates we're just trying to
figure out how to keep up with what
fandom is going to mean in a world where
we will soon live in a minority majority
Nation and the television shows we're
dealing with say Sleepy Hollow would be
this year's example or Scandal are shows
which are dealing with diversity and in
more complex ways fans often reproduce
incredibly narrow stereotypes when they
think about that diversity that fandom
Still Remains a largely white space and
in most fan conventions I go to there's
inevitably a panel where a group of
white people sit around two or three
people of color and ask why aren't there
more people like you here and the result
is that those people don't come back
next time right you know so being
grilled in that way is not a very
productive way to foster a politics of
diversity and so in so far as fandom has
been useful as a way of thinking forward
about gender and sexuality I'm now
struggling to think about what are the
exclusions or marginalizations or
hierarchies the silences that come into
play where we talk about race uh in
America today and I think there's a lot
of lot fandom will would have to answer
for by those axis so so I'm not claiming
this is a radical transformation rejects
everything the commercial culture around
it I am saying that it is more diverse
more open to explore critique than the
media that it's built on and it's in
part because of the social structures
that support that questioning in some
areas and not in
others uh uh I'd like to I'd like to
sort of almost pause in a certain way
although I think the argument about
Henry's ideas will continue but I want I
I don't want too much time to elapse
before we turn to uh uh your time at MIT
Henry and we can I think continue the
discourse of your ideas but look in a
way what we what we were saying
essentially was that uh your your your
uh your early years your high school
years uh uh encouraged you or uh uh LED
you to certain forms of study later on
that had to do with popular culture and
the kinds of the kinds of experiences
you you you you you yourself had found
so meaningful uh we didn't mention
science fiction or you're dressing
dressing up in Goth outfits which I
regret and I still imagine Henry the
teenager dressed as a goth um um that
would be a little ahistorical but I did
wear trench coats um all the way through
high school and did feel a strong
connection with goth culture especially
post Coline when the notion of a trench
coat Mafia came into play right so after
that I wore a black trench coat when I
went to speak in high schools and
including some the trench coats were
banned uh and sort of Daring the
principal to make me take it off uh and
that spoke a lot to the politics of
cultural self-representation that was
going on in some of in some of those
schools well so one way to make the
transition to your time at MIT is to ask
you about uh am some of you may not know
this but among other apart from being a
riveting teacher Henry was also a housem
and had a much more intimate connection
to the MIT cult undergraduate culture
than most professors do and I wonder if
you'd talk a little bit about how you
think your time at MIT not only shaped
your own thinking and attitudes but also
more generally what you thought about
MIT your views of MIT well for 14 years
I was housem at senior house which to my
mind was the most robust community that
I've ever been able to participate in
and it's a community during most of the
time that was under siege by the mm
Administration who inevitably are
spooked or frightened by the kind of
radical difference that senior house can
absorb it was to my pride one of the
most queer friendly dorms at the MIT
campus if not the most friendly it was a
place where there was lots of
experimentation with identity where
there's a strong kind of
anti-authoritarian or anarchistic
culture and it was a place that kept
students sane and safe uh who might not
have fit otherwise within the MIT system
so from my point of view it was a
culture that is work worth defending and
worth defending vigorously so much of my
time there was was working with those
students and I learned an enormous
amount from working with the students
inside that dorm but also providing them
a model of how to argue effectively for
their own interest within a system that
of where they were often stigmatized
often treated as not really truly the
card of MIT and so forth and helping
them win battles and accept defeats and
battles that were fought along the away
as the administration sought ways to to
rein in what they saw as the darker
sides of that of that culture um I my
sense is that they suffer suffered then
and suffer now enormously from
stereotypes that people in MIT have
about what senior house is what its
values are what its core system is at
the heart I saw a community where people
gather 40 50 years later at steer roast
as one of the largest alumni events that
MIT has and give energies and support to
a community of students which threatens
MIT frankly which wants everyone's
identification to be with the institude
and not with their their living group so
I see one of the most important things I
did in MIT was working with the students
in that dorm and providing as much
support for it as I could through the
times that are there and particularly
the final four or five years there which
I felt that MIT had become risk adverse
and liability obsessed and that those
things make it very difficult to support
a rigorous student culture at The
Institute so I'm I'm I I think it it was
and my how I worked with those students
really grows out of being committed to
cultural studies being committed to an
idea that that there's dignity there's
respect that our our core value should
be building Community supporting
different diversity and allowing people
to explore and develop their own modes
of cultural expression even if some of
them were unorthodox or radical from
other people's points of view it's also
the community that supports the Arts at
MIT probably as vigorously as you know
as any other part of the Institute is
the number of students involved in
student drama student music Student Art
production in that dorm is extraordinary
and all you have to do is walk down the
hall of senior house and see the
creative expression that that that's
taking taking place there so I one of my
biggest regret I have two regrets about
leaving MIT one was leaving CMS and the
other is leaving senior house uh other
parts of MIT I have less regrets about
leaving okay uh talk a little bit about
about the way in which your time at MIT
shaped your thinking Henry well I I
think you know I think to be at one of
the world's to be a humanist in one of
the world's largest and most important
technological institutions is to be a
walking talking
oxymoron right you know that there's a
contradiction built into doing the
humanities in MIT but that meant that
but that that's also the contradiction
we face in the culture at large in a
period of prolonged media change the
period of media and transition is the
phrase that we both have put a lot of
our energies into trying to explore that
is if technological change is driving
much of the changes of the culture we
cannot do cultural studies without
understanding the role of technology in
the culture I was lucky to arrive here
at a time that the foundations for what
comparative media studies would be was
built by people like yourself right that
David has been a champion of of popular
culture of Television studies from quite
early on had assembled a team of gifted
Scholars from a variety of disciplines
who were committed to doing
multi-disciplinary work about media and
popular culture at MIT and I felt really
privileged to be mentored by you to be
invited into that community and to make
a difference and that is foundational to
what CMS became that we you and I
disagreed over the years on a number of
things but I think at the core why you
know one of the things I respect so much
about you David is your own commitment
to the Dignity of Everyday People thanks
to the importance of citizenly discourse
to the value of multi-disciplinary work
and particularly to the role of history
in understanding media change and so
those are never thought my admiration
for Henry would be
increased but but it's happened you know
and so finding myself in that finding
myself in that context pav the way for
what we built and then the partnership
William was every bit as foundational to
building a notion of what comparative
media studies could be that again I have
such enormous gratitude for everything
I've learned from David especially in
the OR from William especially in the
international Arena especially in terms
of historical perspectives especially in
terms of his his his diplomatic ability
to diffuse problems uh at a time we used
to joke about the problem dour you know
the problem of the day as we were
struggling to hold this thing together
and make it work and I think the
greatest greatest thing we've
accomplished is the quality of our
students and I now work with a number of
CMS students on the west coast I see
them all over the world we trained the
generation who we wanted to think Beyond
academic careers the goal originally was
about 40% going into University post 60%
into other things to be leaders in those
other areas and we pulled that off right
if you look at the 40%
uh who are academics people like Asin
pacher you know are extraordinary
leaders in the field who are worth
paying attention to and worth are really
I feel enormous successes but if you
talk to the people in Industry we have
people at the top of ety and Kickstarter
some of the companies that have been
transformative in the recent digital
economy we have people in key roles in
educational technology we have people
who are pushing in forward trans media
storytelling in a variety of ways that
they came out of a program that had a
commitment to application as well as
Theory and the phrase applied humanism
was a controversial one while I was here
it's still should be a controversial one
it was never meant to be an easy phrase
but I think we've created a generation
of people who embody that in their work
and are still in contact with each other
across silos which is very much what we
set out to do and so my work has
partially been about fostering those
those students and I now carry those
ideas with me to USC so I taught in the
fall last year course on on how to be a
public intellectual essentially and it
really was looking at how to do a public
facing dimension of your research how to
help young PE the the PhD students learn
to communicate more effectively through
the Press through blogosphere through
oped pieces how to be committed to
opening up a dialogue with the public
about their research and we a number of
the people we brought through were
people like Sam Ford like the folks from
the education arcade here who have done
the really groundbreaking work thinking
about how we mix Research into practice
and so that dimension of CMS is also
something I carry with me from MIT to
the other work that I do and it's
something I think about every
day one of the things that uh I learned
when I was talking to Henry preparing
for this conversation is that uh one of
his most recent and interesting gigs is
that he's on the jury for the Peabody
awards this year the Peabody awards as
some of you must know uh uh are are are
awards given to television and radio uh
uh programming both uh fiction and
non-fiction programming of all sorts and
they're among the probably the the most
distinguished Television Awards uh uh of
their kind uh and it seemed to me that
uh and Henry had mentioned to me that
his work on the pebody jury had
reimmersed him in a tremendous amount of
contemporary television and radio and we
thought that might be an opportunity for
us to talk a bit more about issues that
are at the center of his work but also
in some degree my own perspectives uh so
Henry let's begin by by let me begin
just by asking me what what your sort of
general impression is of the Welter of
new material that you've been looking at
has it has it changed your sense of the
media landscape in some ways well I I
it's been an extraordinary process I
mean to be a jury member
keep in mind there are about 2,000
entries that come into the Peart award
group to to measure and all of them have
to be seen by at least two members of a
14 me member jury so you spent an
extraordinary amount of time looking at
television from all over the world
looking at television from all kinds of
networks all kinds of modes of
production as well as radio uh as well
as web-based content uh ever escalating
num number of different kinds of modes
of production across many many
categories that no one none of none of
us watch all of those categories in our
everyday life so drilling into
documentary for me has been a revelation
and something I'm thinking deeply about
because I'm a pop culture guy and I
don't watch a lot of documentaries the
overall quality of what's being produced
is extraordinary I mean I think that and
you're seeing groups like Al jazer which
really Al jazer America that just
started as a network less than 14 months
ago produce consistently high quality
work which has asked questions that no
other piece of American Media is asking
and doing it with the highest
Professional Standards from the west but
not necessarily beholding to the same
frames that we see in us-based have seen
in us-based media before that's
extraordinary to see we're seeing
massive numbers of documentaries that go
briefly through the theater and go
directly to the web to the on to
television via Independent Lens and
point of view and dozens of other series
that are showing documentary we're
seeing quality drama you can't even
count the number of quality dramas that
are produced right now across a range of
genres you're seeing the explosion of
diversities and platforms right yes so
so I and I think I was telling you just
a little while over ago or t that that I
think when the history of Television is
written the last 18 months will
represent one of those tipping points
where everything from the kickstarter
funding of ironica Mars to the role of
Hulu Amazon Netflix um so Xbox in
production and distribution of
Television are changing fundamentally
what we mean by television in our
culture and what counts as quality whose
interest are represented and we're
starting to see things like Sleepy
Hollow as I mentioned earlier represent
diversity and fundamentally New Way
Sleepy Hollow is a massive a show but uh
at the same time it's got it's a it's a
show that's got more minority cast
members than the white protagonist uh
and which is forcing it to deal with the
black family in a totally different way
than I've seen on television to see the
Multicultural workplace in ways we
haven't seen on television before and
because it goes back and forth in time
to represent the history of race in
America in radically different ways you
introduced black history during the
Revolutionary War period is something we
can discuss and represent on American
television so everywhere I look I'm
seeing incredibly great things now we
were arguing that this may could be just
a transitional moment and right my my
theory is that we may in a moment like
the moment of the 1970s for American
movies that is say an astonishingly Rich
moment the moment of you know all those
remarkable film partly a function of the
fact that television had become so
dominant that the movies were liberated
in a certain way but it didn't last and
I'm wondering whether or not you know
then what happened in the 80s and 90s
where Star Wars and Schwarzenegger
movies succeeded all the wonderful films
that had been made in the early and
middle 70s I'm wondering if that's a
moment like if we may be in such a
moment of Television so we always are
the glass half full glass half empty Duo
up here but I think I think there's I
think that there is some truth and some
value in wondering what are the
conditions which will sustain the level
of cultural production and creativity
that we're T we're seeing at the present
at the present moment and I think that's
a very real question so one analogy to
the 70s that would be interesting is
whether broadcast television is now the
the the Dr dittles and you know the big
bloated Hollywood epics that were being
coming out alongside of which the Mean
Streets and the Nashville's and so forth
are defining their identities and if the
web and web production which is lowering
the cost lowering barriers to
Marketplace and as resulting in more
diverse producers entering the system
are the the kind of Challengers the
gorillas who will challenge it and so
what comes out the other side
particularly postc Comcast merger is
something to be very concerned about cuz
Comcast merger could signal some of the
concentration in the digital sphere that
many of us have been concerned about or
at least the death of net neutrality
which will then make the participatory
dimensions of the web harder to achieve
and sustain so there are danger points
to pay attention to as we think about
that that level of creativity we know
that change is comes in jerks right it's
not it's not a revolution that's one and
then we go on it's a series of evolution
and so there's progress and regression
there's there's pushing there's people
pushing for New Opportunities some of
which are achieved some of which fail
fail to materialize so it's easy to be
an optimist at any moment because you
can see all the change that's possible
but it also realistically if you look at
the larger view there are going to be
push backs and some of the changes we're
seeing right now may not be sustained
well Henry let me ask you to comment on
something else we discussed briefly
earlier but I think is really worth
expanding on uh we ran a confence
confence uh a median transition
conference after you left devoted to
what we call the instability of
platforms it was called uh uh it was
called unstable platforms the Peril and
promise of transition and uh essentially
what we're talking about there has to do
with the sort of immense variety of ways
in which uh uh let's limit ourselves
just to narrative forms are being
delivered today and this instability is
uh potentially very disturbing because
it's it it seems unending I wonder if
you have the comment about that well I
mean I I we can think of a several ways
in which it's potentially disturbing as
well as ways that it's potentially
liberating one would be the inability to
Archive what's being produced right it's
already easier to write the history
history of the first decade of film than
the history of the first decade of the
web we are not holding on to these
things if the platforms are constantly
changing chapters of our history will be
lost and our ability to understand the
past it's someone who studies Comics we
are just now getting to the point where
Comics have forcefully
reclaimed 100 Years of cultural
production as a Canon that we can
actually draw on and make sense of the
history of the medium and that artists
are building on and quoting in ways
where they Count On A literacy of their
readers to understand what's going on
digitally that's going to be very hard
to sustain and so we are losing things
that are un that we will not get back
and so the illusion that the web has
everything on it denies the real ity
that the history of the web is losing
things daily and uh that history is an
endangered species in a digital digital
culture the second is that if if artists
are preoccupied with changing
platforms uh they are not actually
preoccupied with the nature of their
medium and the genres and materials in
it and I think the game industry is a
great example of that where if the if
the basic tools of your medium shift
every two to three
years the depth of the medium has not
achieved what its potential art you know
as someone who is an early to Proclaim
games as a potential art form it's
continually disappointed by the
superficiality of the stories and
experiences that are offered us by games
compared to the technical sophistication
so the technology is growing our depth
of understanding of the media or how it
can express the world is not has not
matured and that I think is a deeply
troubling development and I would argue
technological instability plays a
crucial role in making that you know
making that happen that said I also get
very excited by the kind of unexpected
jux positions of media that are possible
in a moment of change and my fascination
with trans media is partially the idea
that we're seeing new combinations of
media new mixtures of affordances new
kinds of experiences new experimentation
that is incredibly rich and we're seeing
deeper and great things so I would say
the Lizzy Bennett Diaries last year
which takes uh Shane Austin's Pride and
Prejudice and translates it into the
world of social media was a profound
intervention right that it's mixing
webcam footage with Twitter and so forth
it actually tells us something
interesting about the world that
Austin's describing in the politics of
reputation of Gossip of social
connection and so forth that it found a
way to use these emergent forms to
reopen an older text to a new generation
of viewers there's a real lesson there
in me about the nature of media
transition isn't there Henry because the
older text is stabilizes in some
stabilizes the process in some sense
it's as if it's it shows you that
transformation always has elements of
continuity in it yeah so it's it's no
accident that it's drawn on but it's
also no accident that it's deeply
disrespectful in tone to a kind of
Heritage version of Jane Austin right I
mean
Lydia uh you know is a is a is a
fascinating character who speaks in
contemporary slang and really knows how
to play to the webcam those kinds of
characters
the connections are there if we know the
original text the con they open up a way
of understanding that text to new
readers and the fact that it's a story
told across dozens of channels then the
the reader puts those pieces together
and has the experience of an epistolary
novel of sorts right of these different
kinds of textual systems being brought
together not that Austin wrote an
epistolary novel but the form of the
this early history of the novel is
reproduced here with there are plenty of
letters in her books though yeah yeah so
I so I think there's very interesting
things that are happening right now
because of the instability of platforms
even though I share the sense that there
are several dangers attached to the
instability of platforms if if you
um were thinking about
uh the experiments in narrative that
that that you've paid attention to over
the course of your career are there one
or two especially recent ones that you
would point to especially that seem seem
uh to you really
significant now I'm thinking about some
of the programs that you that you had
mentioned to me earlier for example oh
which well well for House of Cards as an
as an instance well I mean I I I there
are so many rich and ex interesting
narratives I'm struggling to try to
figure out which ones we pay attention
to getting back to the PE thing one of
the struggles that PE deals with when it
currs to the web right now is whether
text is the best way to describe the new
sets of practices right so Peabody gives
Awards to distinguish
text if you think the era of
interactivity so I'm I am replacing
Janet Murray on the peab board as their
digital person Janet Murray's work deals
with
interactivity she's still in a world
where text or what def or or what
defines it right so it's the
interactivity of the text how to how to
how does an interactive text create set
of structured experiences that readers
have I'm about participation so I'm
trying I was trying to get the board to
think about something like the
phenomenon of nerd Fighters uh John John
and Hank Green who do YouTube videos
that have been incredibly effective at
creating political awareness social
mobilization social sensitivity among
young people they explain everything
they just put up one about uh what's
happening with Russia and the Ukraine uh
and five minutes on on YouTube that
really lay it out and a language young
people understand but it's not one text
it's not one program they produced a
variety of texts that distributed across
a variety of media channels uh including
both written word and audio visual
material they're a novelist and one of
their novels about young people in
cancer have just been turned through a
film that's coming out later this year
so how does the category of the Peabody
recognize the contribution beyond that
it's not just their writing it's
thousands and thousands of nerd Fighters
who've made their own videos responding
to the provocations they've offered once
a year take over the top ranks of
YouTube to call attention to social
causes and charity so does that is that
a is that something pebody can give an
award to so are you thinking about a new
category like a a process category or I
don't know can we think about can we
think about distinguished process in a
way that's very different from what
journalism could be thought of as a
distinguished process uh and I I don't
know that my thinking is far enough
along leave aside the board so I'm not
announcing some new development by pe
I'm using PE to ask a question about is
Nar is narrative text the right way to
think about the modes of expression
which are so Innovative and interesting
at the current moment or is the text
simply a box we put around so I went
around someone in Europe had asked me a
couple of summies ago to talk about the
future of content and one of the things
I discovered looking at content which is
a awful word and we use in Stupid Ways
well if you look at content in the
dictionary content is that which is
contained as in a table of contents or
the contents of a bottle and I think the
nature of current media is that it's not
contained so is is content even the
right word to describe the experiences
we're having that are dispersed across
media that are spread across the web
that are that have Grassroots and
Commercial participation in the
production of that lead to new
experiences that move across National
borders to all of those ways in which
media is not totally contained change
fundamentally the categories we use to
to talk about it so that I think is why
I was grappling with you know your
question at first was I don't narrative
Innovation yeah sure but that's just the
tip of an iceberg and it may in fact Bo
put us in that box that I've been
struggling with and how to talk about
the web since I became a Peabody juror
uh that most of the things that really
excite me about the web today aren't
content and aren't programs and aren't
text as we've traditionally understood
them
if if
you had to
pick one or two texts or one or two one
or two one or two processes that struck
you as as significant what would they be
well I I think I think the expansion of
I mean I think the biggest revolution of
the 20 year 25 years of my career has
been the growth of access to the means
of cultural production and circulation
in the hands of more diverse publics I
used to call that participatory culture
I still think that word's useful I now
but people have sort of said that the
phrase participatory culture sounds
settled it's as if we've resolved it we
now live in a participatory culture I
now talk about a more participatory
culture which implies movement change
Borderlands that we are moving that
there has been definite progress toward
a world where more people have access to
Greater communicative capacities than
ever before but many people are left out
of it and so I'm excited at what's
happened already as we've Diversified
who produces media in our culture and
the ways in which that stuff collides
with mainstream media and forces
mainstream media to respond in different
ways um that would be for my mind the
process that that excites me the mo the
most I'm excited by Something Like
Comics which has gone in the 20 25 years
that I was of my career from something
that would have I remember when I first
got here a Watchman was coming out and
Dark Knight Returns was coming out and I
was sitting down with a editor from a
university press who was asking about it
and I went on a long Rift as you can see
I'm capable of long Rifts I went in a
long Rift about what was exciting about
those books and she listened intently
and then she said at the end of the day
they aren't they in the business of
making money and I asked what business
she was in and whether her goal was to
lose money and she walked away right uh
but that was that moment when art
spiegelman's mouse was first coming out
and spiegelman's goal was to make comics
into an art form and I would say if we
look today that any given month there
are rich texts coming out of comics that
have the weight of a serious novel that
are posing culturally interesting
questions and maybe even would have
satisfied my friend at the University
press because they broken rid the men
and capes genre which had been the
central constraint on them as they move
into a world where more and more artists
come through the web more and more comic
graphic novels are sold through
bookstores than specialty shops they
explode of that market I think and the
shift and cultural hierarchy that that
represents would be another key key
change um and and and television terms
it's television and television has also
undergone that process what you know and
I think that we can have quality dramas
that look like dtown Abbey and our own
Masterpiece Theater well we can also
have quality dramas whether it's
breaking bad or Orange is the New Black
uh that come from different places and
we can have quality dramas that are also
genres right so that that are in space
or in courtrooms or in doctor's offices
or whatnot and the fluidity of
possibilities right now because we've
expanded who's producing media is
enormous and who has voice at the table
so I'm doing an event in LA and another
at the beginning of April where we're
bringing 10 female showrunners from
television together to talk and I had a
list of 40 female showrunners that I was
trying to draw on to recruit people for
this particular conversation who
represent a range of genres and some of
the most important shows on television
today are produced by women that would
not have been the case 25 years ago when
I first arrived at MIT you should Define
showrunner for some of the audience well
it's a slippery term right and so in
this context I'm you the showrunner is a
title on its own but we also their
titles like Creator headwriter executive
producer all of whom more or less are
the creative intelligence behind the
television show so the showrunner is
responsible for the continuity and
conception of a Series in television
terms the director comes in and does an
episode and leaves right so the aure
theory that people use to talk about
Hollywood doesn't work for television at
all it can't be the director the the
creative intelligence and then the
showrunner also becomes the voice of the
show he's essentially a supervising
producer even though the title
is a little strange because they use the
title and more and very often they also
play a kind of writing role on the show
right that's a little different from a
supervising producer and film who rarely
wrote the film right and TV whereas
there are some television series JMS and
Babylon 5 comes to mind where almost
every episode was written by J John J
Michaels trzinski in television we there
much more create opportunities for that
and so the having women moved to a point
where the number of women in the on the
script writing trade is gone down over
the last 10 years but the number of
women controlling series creatively has
gone up and it's an interesting Paradox
but as that happens we're seeing
different kinds of stories different
kinds of characters uh and the future is
kind of interesting to think about what
will happen as the you know these women
were almost all mentored by men what
will happen when they have a chance to
Mentor younger women and that there's
some continuity of female creativity in
the television industry is something I
think will be very interesting to
observe get your questions ready I we'll
make a transition I have one last uh
General perspective to ask ask Henry
about and then when we conclude that I
hope the audience will begin to engage
with with Henry uh let's talk a little
bit more deeply Henry about what has
been in some sense the implicit theme of
a great deal of what you've been saying
our category media and transition in a
certain way what you've been saying is
that we're in a moment of really
profound deep
transformation uh how long it will last
is problematic and questionable uh how
deep it will go is questionable but make
some comments about it as a general
category and why it's useful for media
study well I I think part you know if we
think about what um the birth of media
studies partially it's someone like
Marshall mclan talking beyond the single
medium to talk comparatively across
media channels and platforms and so
forth but mclan had ultimately in my
mind such an ahistorical conception of
what media was where the traits of a
media are defined in an essential way so
we talk about hot and cold media I think
understanding change gives us a broad
set of questions to ask about media that
cut across media platforms media the
individual text and allow us to
reconfigure them in a by looking at
history so you know media change is a
question we have to address at about the
present moment it's futur looking it's
it's about it's about where things are
going but the only way to answer that
question is to Look Backwards to the
past and to see the connections between
our current moment of media change and
earlier moments where Transformations
took place whether that's the shift for
moral ity to literacy or the Gutenberg
printing press or the Gutenberg
parenthesis has has been discussed often
at the media in transition conferences
or whether that's uh the birth of the
novel or the explosion of new modern
mass media the late 19th 20th century or
you know the shfs from C broadcast to
Cable there's so many moments of media
change that give us insights that we can
use of the current moment so to my mind
the phrase media and transition what's
given its power is that it invites us to
look both back forwards and backwards at
the same time that encourages to think
about the future through the lens of the
past and the strength of that conference
in particular has always been the
bringing together of historians who work
on all different time periods with
people who are doing Cutting Edge work
looking at digital media that is just
emerging or hasn't even fully taken
shape we can talk about an anticipatory
aesthetic and the way Janet Murray who I
mentioned earlier was really thinking
about how do we imagine New Media based
on the early experimentations how do we
predict or anticipate where media might
be going aesthetically we're also are
talking about social change or political
change or economic change that's wrought
that's part that media is part of the
challenge is how to do it without
putting the technology at the center
right and so I try very actively in my
own writing to never use technology as
the noun of a sentence you know that it
should not be the active subject it's
not technology does something it's not
technology does something to us it's
what are do with technology how does
technology fit how how do we fit
technology into existing social and
cultural structure and how does
technology become the battleground of
which which competing bids for change
get fought and negotiated not technology
does things but we do things because
techn we have access to Technologies we
didn't have before and that's where a
study of media and transition seems to
be a very very useful
concept
audience
maybe you should go to the microphone so
we can hear you see the microphones on
either side
people how do we find out about the
event in La uh I'm probably going I will
probably be announcing it in a second
conference that's the following day
that's going to be at UCLA on the
futures of Television we'll announce
them through my blog at Henry jenkins.
org probably Monday a best guess I'm
trying to collect all the biographies
from the women and their officers are
slow getting them to me so it'll be some
point next week we will formally
announce it and set up the registration
process for any of you who have access
to La well there'll be two days of
events the the women women make create
television event which is sort of made
as a joking tribute to Richard shekels
the men who make the movies and the
future of Television futures of
Television event will be back to back so
two days of interesting thinking about
media and media change from folks inside
the television
industry it would be helpful when you uh
ask your question if you would identify
yourself people microphones on either
side so go and go up stand at the
microphone I can talk no I want you to
because they're recording is the because
they're being recorded we'll start over
here with Ian hi uh Ian condry uh CMS
thanks Henry it's great to have you back
um I wanted to hear more about this uh
politics and participation and pop
culture issue and I'm you mentioned nerd
Fighters I'm curious to hear about if
there's another example or two that
particularly exemplifies some of the
possibilities for what can happen there
and related to that I I'm very
interested to hear your thoughts on the
questions of crowdsource production and
exploitation um and it really it's very
striking to me how if you have a world
where people are producing things and no
money is in changing hands then one of
the things people say is well shouldn't
they be paid for this you know and and
shouldn't people get a little money for
this if other some people are profiting
but then as soon as some people start
getting paid then somehow it's
exploitation for everybody or and either
they're paid too little or the people
aren't paid at all and there's an
interesting kind of paradox in there
because I always hear well people should
be paid but then you realize it's when
people start to be paid that
exploitation really comes to the four so
I know you've been thinking about it I'd
be really curious to hear your thoughts
all right so yeah I I hope I can
remember both questions long enough to
answer them the Pol the politics
question I've been part of the youth and
participatory politics Network that the
MacArthur Foundation has set up it's
about a dozen Scholars from all over the
US multiple disciplines quantitative
qualitative research really trying to
get a deep dive into where American
young people are in terms of their
political and Civic activity the news
we're getting is generally I think
optimistic both in terms that more young
people are care about the society around
them are taking various kinds of actions
to change the world uh and the divver
and there's more diversity there and and
more Equity across some of those
activities than might have been
Advantage imagined by
uh previous
accounts Robert putam comes immediately
to mind but Malcolm Gladwell also comes
to mind as Skeptics of this and we're
proving it quantitatively we're proving
it qualitatively by Deep diving my team
at USC is writing a book which
tentatively is called by any medium
necessary um which is about sort of
critiques on the one hand the idea that
that online politics is relatively
superficial the whole slack ofst sort of
notion on the other hand the guide of a
Twitter
Revolution so my my our notion is that
our that the groups we are studying are
committing politics by every media
necessary the word necessary being the
key part of that sentence they're using
a variety of tools that are appropriate
Technologies for the communities they're
trying to communicate in and they're
doing certain functions by face Toof
face and Street protest and public art
and print culture and radio and as well
as some things that use Twitter and and
YouTube and these other other platforms
we're more interested in how does
participation take place and how how is
the Civic imagination What role the
storytelling play so we just did an a
webinar series with 20 young activists
from different groups talking about the
role of Storytelling in their practice
the why why telling stories through is
such a central part how they approach
and the essence of it would be that
young people today find the language of
politics both exclusive and repulsive
right exclusive and so far is you've
already to have a lot of knowledge of
policy policy won style knowledge to get
involved in the process at all right and
repulsive in the sense that it's so
charged with partisan bickering and
gamesmanship so they're turning towards
stories to express a shared cultural
understanding of what political change
might look like and using those stories
to mobilize to educate to translate the
real world into a language and many of
those stories come from popular popular
culture um
so I just saw a video this morning
someone sent me of I don't even know who
who put it out of a first world kid
looks like you're you looks like England
undergoing a a a future War a science
fiction War where you know the society
the society is being bombed she's being
hurdled from place to place she's
dealing with all the problems of being a
refugee and you know and the the C CH
line is just because it isn't happening
here doesn't mean it's not happening in
the world and it's that pulling away of
the science fiction frame or the Imagine
better Foundation took Hunger Games and
pulled out all the OCC the the politics
for the occupi era uh underline that and
used that to express an alternative
critique especially of Revlon say which
did an ad campaign where they celebrated
the Fashions and looks of the capital
sort of said maybe we should be paying
attention to the districts they now are
partnering with labor organizations
particularly those for lowincome minimum
wage workers fast food workers in
particular where the three finger that's
the other hand the three finger salute
from Hunger Games is going to be a
central s symbol in this movement that
goes from the fan Community to labor
organizers who are trying to organize
McDonald's and Burger King and Wendy's
and the other fast food things so we're
seeing the vocabulary's travel we're
seeing dreamers undocumented youth
fighting for right education rights
using the metaphor of the superhero
we're seeing Muslim youth using radio
talk television themes and uh comedy to
talk to express what it is to be is an
Islamic Islamic and America after 911 so
we're seeing some political activities
there that are buil on what i' called
participatory culture we're trying to
document that both in terms of a book
and a digital archive uh that will live
online and bring together a lot of these
videos so people can incorporate them as
educational resources both in schools
after school things so they're stable
and protected it goes back to what we
said about unstable platforms we're
protect we're preserving And archiving
work that's come out very tactically
very short term from that Henry isn't
there a dark side to what you're saying
though aren't there skin heads who make
complicated use of the media oh yeah
media forms and so forth just because
it's participatory doesn't mean it's
Progressive right right everything I'm
describing could easily be done by the
tea party right uh everything I'm
describing is being done by Neo-Nazi
groups across Europe
right I that that many of these groups
have many of these groups have
conflicted relations to popular culture
for example right that it's not a
language that comes very naturally to
you after 30 years of culture War
rhetoric against against popular culture
but we are seeing it and there was a
kind of libertarian re remix of hunger
games that came out at about the same
time as the Harry Potter version that
was sort of not about economic
inequality but about government
overreach in terms of trying to
understand the story of The Hunger Games
so I'm not saying I think I think the my
goal is to Foster more mechanisms of
participation and more diversity of
participation so that we have an
infrastructure through which other
battles can be fought right so you know
with the Democrats and Republicans
should be equally concerned with
ensuring democracy they don't happen to
be right voting rights suppression is a
very real concern and it's directed by
one party against voters in the other
party but we it used to be the case that
we all felt like the infrastructure of
voting was something that everyone had a
stake in and once you had the ability to
vote then we fought elections and we
termin the outcome and I would say in
the same way as we move toward a
politics that's more informal Less in
less governmental that's more
participatory we create a space of free
speech and free expression and
Collective organization in within which
then we battle over ideological divides
that may be as as equally deep but I'm
committed to fostering participatory
cult culture more than I'm fostered a
par promoting a particular ideology that
may get in the way of building some
shared spaces that allow us to pass
through and fight over some of the key
dividing issues of our time now the
labor question man i' I've ran on so
long on that one let me you're
absolutely right that this issue of free
labor and economic exploitation is an
incredibly complex one that the book
spreadable media which I our book the
book I wrote with Sam Ford and joh josua
green that came out of the convergence
culture Consortium here struggles with
it a lot and I I'm not as the books come
out I'm less and less satisfied with how
we resolve it in that book it's always
the case that things get more
complicated but I think yeah that some
parts of the web or have been very much
G governed by gift economies or sharing
economies and it's not simply a matter
of that being unpaid labor so the
solution is to put a give them a
paycheck is you fundamentally alter the
quality of that labor when you bring
commodity culture practices into it I
always use the analogy you have a hot
night over a date gender of your choice
you make out passionately all night you
fall asleep and the next morning you
wake up and there's a $100 bill on the
dresser right has money improved the
relationships between those two people
right was the problem of the inequality
between men and women or the the the
homophobia of our society all about
whether someone got a paycheck or not I
don't think so right and so we we have
aspects of our life that are deeply
social deeply Civic goes back to what I
said about Community whether in the
Baptist Church of my parents or senior
house here at MIT where those sense of
communities take press and over economic
questions the problem is that in our
culture gift economies or sharing
economies exist in a context of
capitalism they cannot be pure sharing
economies pure gift economies so there
is no simple way out in our culture we
know a lot about moving from between
exchanges based on value to exchanges
based on value I give you money you give
me a product we know how to go from
exchanges based on Worth to exchanges
based on worth I provide a Ser I provide
a favor to you you provide a favor to me
it's where we cross those streams that
it becomes a problem if you commodify
something that I produced as a gift and
sell it back right not not just that I
regift it but I sell it on eBay I
probably have violated a set of social
norms about what's acceptable if I take
something that was produced as a
commodity and I Mass redistribute it as
gifts to all of my friends I take your
song that you put on the line I
redistribute it as a gift I've also
created a crisis point in those
relationships and I think we are not
very good we don't have good vocabulary
yet to think about how we sort through
those relations I think the Free Labor
critique gets us so far and then it
abandons us because it doesn't have an
alternative for what a viable sense of
the relationship between sharing
economies and commodity culture actually
can look like I think as a critique of
some practice the question is are people
being exploited are people do people
know that they're being exploited are
the trade-offs that they're making
conscious choices that are being made
and fully articulated choices the gift
the free free labor critique goes a long
way to help us ask those questions does
it provide us with an alternative of how
the the interface between those systems
of value could operate no it doesn't I
and I think it tricks Us in the thinking
throw money at the problem and it'll go
away and I I don't think that's that's
the right solution for these mismatches
that we're seeing emerge in digital
culture over here excellent um is it
working okay good yes um so by the way
the answer to the $100 bill thing is you
take that dollar that the money and then
you use it to uh take your next date out
somewhere really nice um that that's
pass it Forward I like that as a as a
solution uh what I was going to uh
mention is um we you actually talked
about online political communities and
um and the kind of uh Guerilla media
that appears and when that was kind of
kicking up during the sort of uh I I
would say uh the the anti-mainstream
media communities or during the uh
so-called occupy age which um many I
would say within my age bracket would
argue the Occupy age might be uh might
have been killed or or stomped or
infiltrated by um certain uh higher
Powers I guess uh a question I would ask
is what are the chief values or
exchanges that cause people to bring
information that they found from a media
space or a digital space into the real
space real life I I mean I think I think
they're the same values which cause us
to pass along media content in an online
space I'm not sure there's radical
difference we pass along media content
to other people because we think it's
valuable as a kind of social or cultural
currency because it's information that
allow in the case of occupy it would be
information that allowed that Community
to more effectively critique the the Mal
distribution of wealth in America to
take aim at institutions that are that
need to be challenged and questioned and
reformed uh it in the case of a fan
Community it could be a vivid story or
image that we think is good raw material
for telling the stories that that
Community wants to express about race
sexuality gender and so forth that we
it's about resourcing it's about taking
materials from one place and bringing
them to another uh and so the qu value
of media for me is the conversations
that en enables us to have once we share
that media with each other that it's
about me media exists as part of a
conversation that we're having within
within our culture and I think that
political conversations are one version
of that but there are other kinds of
conversations we have that are perfectly
mundane but very important about how we
live our lives how we protect our teeth
from rotting out of our mouths how we
put put food on the table you know all
of the very basic things of being a
human being are also important things
that we talk about and we often use
media to talk about those things
also thanks over on this you have a
followup I'm sorry oh no I said thanks
great over here um identify yourself
okay I'm Ry as a student of Ian uh
thinking about MIT and USC as media in
and of themselves could you compare them
for us how how do the ideals change h
yeah I I I think it's that's it's very
very interesting to think in the in
those terms I mean I you know what I
always loved about MIT was an MIT is the
anti- Harvard right so it's and and this
is not about Brand This is not simply
about Corp University branding and
differentiation that in so far as
Harvard was created as an instrument of
the American aristocracy right the the
the educ the elites economically
educationally and all of its values flow
from that including the notion of
passing on you know Legacy Kids access
to admission and honorary degrees and
you know pomping circumstance and what I
loved about MIT and its mythology but I
think in its core is that it's a
meritocracy that it is deep you know the
fact that it refused to give an honorary
degree Winston Churchill after the end
of World War II says a lot about MIT
that it's about it you know that that
that Harvard looks to the past and MIT
looks to the Future now when we
differentiate that and again I'm
painting in Broad strokes but I think
it's largely true right uh and that as
we as we look at USC USC is a space
that's still struggling to Define what
its identity is going going to be um
it's moved dramatically from the
University of spoiled
children uh which has long been known of
which is the place where all of the kids
of the rich who couldn't get into
Harvard go right and so they're the
Dumber kids of the the privileged class
was what USC's reputation was for an
extended period of time I no longer
think that's the case I think the
quality of students were're seeing at
MIT at USC on The Graduate level it's
competitive I think with MIT on the
undergraduate level it's not but I think
that we're seeing gifted students who
worked hard and made good degrees and
got got enough clout enough
opportunities to make make their way
into USC as their standards go up the
students have gone up it struggles is
with the politics of diversity right and
I have to I think I've been deeply
troubled by the racial politics of USC
in relation to the city of Los Angeles
since I got there you you'd have to be
thick not to see some of the stuff
that's that's gone on there especially
when we pass through a a gate of fence
that's been put around the campus since
I arrived there that's intended to
protect the students from the
surrounding community and that seeing
guards there ask every student of color
who passes through to produce idea that
proves that they belong there right I
don't see you know there was an incident
here where the extropia club in MIT sent
letters to all the entering women women
and people of color in one year saying
you don't belong in MIT and that was
deeply troubling and people at all level
of of MIT were troubled by that I meet
administrators at USC who are not
troubled by the presence of the fence
who think this is a good idea and that
troubles me that we had a party at USC
last year where two parties on the same
street one by a white fraternity one by
a black fraternity the LA Police get
pulled in they stop at the white
fraternity and tell people to stay
inside for their own protection and then
raid the black
fraternity right radically different
treatments of exactly the same
phenomenon at exactly the same time it
is very hard to say that USC is done
well by the politics of race and yet
it's surrounded by one of the most
racially diverse cities in America and a
place where racial politics has been as
is really pushed to the four and so
that's what I struggle with when I think
about USC by every other access I'm
enormously excited to be there I think
there's a vision of the future that's
multidisciplinary that's collaborative
that allows you know that has much less
bound to traditional structures of
knowledge and you know I see much less
academic politics at USC frankly than I
saw at MIT and I and I really value that
but the racial politics of USC trouble
me in a deep way and I think the racial
politics of MIT while not non-existent
operate in very different terms and I
see you MIT has dealt better with
diversity overall than I think USC has
done next
question oh I'm you first year graduate
student at CMS and as a student out of
the path of Academia and I'd like to
learn more about media producers with
their responsibilities and possibilities
because for for now we heard lot of
talking about our children is good our
teenagers are well and our senior
citizens well I don't know but what
about the you know the producer side
what's your opinion on that them um I'm
not sure I fully grasp get the question
but I I I think that I think that what
I've if we're talking about cms's
relation to the production side I think
that the kinds of quality students we
produced are students who came to us
seeking the big picture that they
they're students who lived in a moment
of media change understood that the CH
institutions they were working within
were undergoing crisis op crisis points
came to this University to get a bigger
picture of what the future of media
change could be media and transition
going back to what David and I were
talking about and it brought that
expertise with them into those
institutions now traditionally cultural
study would not have had much to say
about cultural workers inside the
industry that there's been an anxiety
about the over influence of Industry on
academic life and that that that's been
a real touch point I don't think we can
afford in our econom economic structure
not to be engaged with industry that the
conversations that constitute media
policy in the United States are shaped
by industry so profoundly that we have
to engage with them in some way and the
economic crisis of the University as
such we're going to have to partner with
them in some ways for funding which
means we've got to figure out what the
terms of that relationship should be and
we have to figure out how to work with
it I think it's nonsense to talk about
talking truth to power if you're not
talking to power and in this country
power is held by Major media companies
and our field if we don't engage with
those companies with our critiques and
with our advice we're we're abdicating
our responsibility as media media
Scholars doesn't mean it's the only
thing we should do do doesn't mean it's
the only kind of students we should
train but it does mean that if we can
figure out a way to train creative
workers who question and change the
institutions they're embedded in we
bring about change in a very different
way than if we simply train we're simply
professional training for people to work
in Industries or we're simply imagining
ourselves in this Ponzi scheme we call
Academia right where if each of us
reproduce ourselves endlessly there will
always be jobs for those people at the
under end of the the pipeline right and
it is a pomy scheme at the end of the
day unless we're ready to have zero
population growth among academics which
would crush graduate education in this
country we've actually got to think
about other places the graduates can go
and Industry is one of those places
where our people can make a
difference yes great over here okay hi
my name is p um and I was wondering if
we could return to your discussion of
race and diversity and um talk about how
you see the work of Stuart Hall and what
you see as the differences if any
between cultural studies and
Multicultural studies and media studies
um and Hall said that if he had to read
another dissertation on The Sopranos he
would scream and that there was a lot
masquerading as cultural studies and So
within Academia could you talk about
some of the tensions and and differences
between those fields o that's not that's
a that's the kind of question I give
students on calls
uh
um let me I mean first of all I have
enormous admiration for steuart Hall and
I think he always functioned as a
conscience on some of the directions the
cultural studies would operate and at
various moments a conscience on a
cultural studies that became overly
academic as well as the cultural studies
that became to too apolitical and I I
think he he achieved over time enormous
balancing effect on U on on the way the
field grew and so I have great
admiration for him I also probably
disagree with some of the things that
steuart Hall said which is that you know
that he I think Ste I'm I steuart Hall
said at one point that if cultural
culture pop culture isn't political I'm
not interested in it right and I'm
interested in culture as culture I'm
interested in popular art I'm interested
in a number of dimensions of popular
culture that don't necessarily lead in a
very direct way to politics but are an
important part of how we live and I
guess it in cultural studies I probably
have somewhat more Fidelity to Raymond
Williams than to steuart hall because of
because of that but on the other hand I
what I value most about steuart Hall was
his willingness to open up and really
deal with the diversity around race
culture and to incorporate materials
that would did not pass through
commercial culture but were culturally
significant to the people who produced
them and that really is very much part
of that idea of culture is ordinary that
culture belongs Stuart Hall tells us in
every mind and every hand and the E is
always that crisis point because when
Raymond William was writing I don't
think he was thinking as far about it
some of the people that steuart Hall
incorporated into the study of of
culture and I think we learn those are
vital forces today that we as a society
have to deal with you know we we we have
to think about diversity in new ways
because the the simple shifts of our
society dictated even even if I didn't
care about people of color which I do
care about people of color obviously but
even if I didn't care about it if I
cared about the society I live in I have
to find a way to think differently about
race or I'm not going I'm not going to
survive and this is a point John Fisk
made in Media Matters more than 20 years
ago that the demographic shifts of
America would shape it shift its culture
in its politics and profound ways and
the the way it would play itself out
would be both through rep
representations that were both popular
fictions and popular news and that those
are the spaces where we'll work through
diversity the web threw a kink in that
right and Fisk was writing that book as
the web is coming into being and what he
describes in that book is very much he
talks about Pirate Radio but he doesn't
talk about digital media as sources for
alternative voices alternative
perspectives by which groups are able to
articulate difference in in terms of the
culture Fisk though in that book when he
talks about technology is very cautious
about inevitable outcomes right and what
FIS says in that book at one point is
that people in the Middle Ages had lines
but it didn't mean everyone got to speak
and I love that quote as a description
of that access to technology is not the
same thing as access to voice it's not
the same thing as access to power and
it's particularly not the same thing as
access to listening and so someone like
Nick calry talks about new forms of
listening being an ethical
responsibility if we're going to live in
a new era of voice and I think what as
we think about diversity right now what
is it that and allows diversity to be
heard it's clear what allows diversity
to be expressed it's not always clear
what allows diversity to be heard and I
think that's a core question we should
be paying attention to so I I totally
did not succeed in answering your
question but hopefully I threw some
enough stuff at it you didn't
notice wi hi I'm wi Kelly in in
literature Henry it's great to have you
back happy to be back when um my
question is about you were talking about
media and transition my question is
about inst institions in transition and
uh it's inspired in part by the amazing
um tour you gave me of the children's
reading room at the library in la oh yes
and so as my question is about libraries
uh which are in transition here at
MIT um my understanding of a a narrative
uh narrative in trans media um migration
is that books um uh have become or or
libraries have become places of social
spaces and fan culture shows us that a
book isn't necessary in order for
reading and social the social exchanges
that books provide to take place uh and
I also understand that libraries have
become more and more social centers uh
and that as books have migrated to
digital um that has opened up other
kinds of fan spaces or work spaces or
Democratic spaces um but I'm also
thinking of that children's room and all
the people who got started on their
Democratic experience through reading
books uh through literacy uh through
through um uh immigration uh and I'm
wondering what commitment libraries
still need to make to books um as a
technology as objects as things that
take up space in our lives and are
expensive uh that have a tradition and a
history uh and um how libraries like our
own at MIT are going to negotiate um
those competing needs I I very important
question and I I have multiple Minds on
it as I am on most things
you know what you're describing the
social space is beautifully demonstrated
by the New Media centers that started at
the Chicago Public Library and have
become really important spaces for young
people across Chicago when I visited the
um media center and there was it was
they they're closed during school hours
and so at 3:00 there were more than a
hundred kids waiting in line outside the
library to get inside the um Media
Center when I was there and that was
just extraordinary to see kids from all
over Chicago all Races all classes
waiting in line to get inside a library
now inside that Library were all kinds
of digital resources but more than
digital resources mentorship that
allowed them to make things to do things
but they're surrounded by books right
and plus chairs that you can sit in and
the result was has been the the number
of books checked out of that collection
is multiplied by 10 the enormous
increase in books because kids are
sitting there they people are playing
the computer and they're waiting to get
on the computer computer and they pick a
book off the shelf and start flipping
through it and discover there's
something interesting there and they
take it home with it so that the two are
not necessarily opposed that that's
that's a space where in fact we're
seeing access to digital technology is
leading people to use books in ways they
didn't before and books as we all know
are marvelous things that we like to to
hold in our hands like that have
affordances that are really amazing uh
and I would hate to see those books go
away but the other part of it is that
mentorship right and the fact that there
are people there who can help them get
better at things they care about and
help connect their passions back to
books I.E The Librarians are very huge
part of it so just as I worry about
libraries without books I especially
worry about libraries without Librarians
who are our major resources and
fostering dialogue with the culture
around us who are the coaches for the
information age and in La we've seen
Librarians get fired from the LA Public
Schools so we have school libraries that
are well stocked and don't have
Librarians uh and that the Librarians
only survive if they can quote teach
overlooking the mentorship that
Librarians provide is teaching and
teaching of a more valuable kind because
it's the passion driven teaching of
schools that is really an important part
of what the librarian does so I don't
know much about what's happening here at
MIT since I left in the library so I
can't localize this but this is an issue
that's plaining out everywhere and I I
care deeply about the future the
Liberian but I don't think that that the
the digital is NE necessarily the enemy
of the print and that the ideal space
for me my utopian space is a pace where
those things can be combined in ways
that benefit each
other um hi Jason lipin uh CMS grad
student also um graduate of the
University of spoiled
children um right um so my question is
about the relationship between uh sort
of theory and practice um and by
practice I mean media produ uction
within uh graduate education
specifically in media studies um I think
one of the things that really interested
me about CMS originally was the
opportunity to both think about and
write about media and Technology but
then also get your hands dirdy and
create things and so I was wondering if
you could talk a little bit about that
sort of original vision and also how
that model I I'm seeing it pop up
everywhere um you know at USC The
Institute for multimedia literacy was
really really formative for me but also
if there other spaces that you think are
are interesting that are um dealing with
whether it be called digital Humanities
or digital art or whatever what your
thoughts are on that well while we're
sitting here talking elsewhere at the
University people are commemorating the
death of Chuck vest right and I it
brings it's left me to think about Chuck
best and inauguration where Steve toscot
one of our colleagues in literature read
a powerful poem on a vision of of what
MIT could be in which he referred to the
MIT seal the man with a book The Man
with the Anvil who are not facing each
other right as as a sort of emblematic
of the culture of MIT and it was just
such a powerful image that stuck in my
head almost 20 years later maybe more uh
I still can recall Steve delivering
those those those lines and that was
very much in my mind and I think in
Williams mind when we were building CMS
was how we got those guy tapped each of
them on the shoulder stepped away and
got them talking to each other is how do
we get the technical side of MIT and the
the intellect the bookish side of MIT
engaged in a dialogue how do we bring
hand and mind together in the spirit of
MIT and does the humanities play a
different role in the context of MIT so
that's part it's part of it you know and
I'm a total hypocrite on this point
because I avoided every production class
I could possibly avoid in grad school
and we really didn't hang out with those
guys who actually made things but I came
I come from a generation of people who
worked with their hands the sheet metal
worker who was my grand grandfather my
father who built buildings and so I have
a deep appreciation of the
understandings that come out of working
with material working with your hands
and understanding what those things can
do that govern me as I thought about
this the other thing was it was governed
by this question of jobs and how do we
break out of the Ponzi scheme of
Academia that I was talking about and we
went around Alex Chisum and I went
around
to 60 70 different organizations
companies and said what do you value
about people who have liberal arts or
Humanities degree and what do you see as
their weakness and the answer we got
over and over again was that what was
valuable was the creativity the breath
of knowledge the ability to think
outside of fixed boxes the downside we
heard over and over again was uh problem
solving brainstorming leadership project
completion those are things that
humanists have done rather badly by and
so the question was can you create
Humanity's la Labs at MIT that Foster
those skills by doing applied resource
research which gets people thinking and
making as part of their degree and we
thought of it as a whole system not just
a set of classes production classes next
to Theory classes and history classes
but the research assistantships that are
provided by comparative media studies
were ones that allowed people to have
appli take what they s in their classes
and immediately applied them to projects
which had real world consequences and
which involve some forms of making
things uh and that we've consciously
built Bridges between the research and
the educational parts of MIT so that
those things are integral to each other
that it's not about just getting money
to ra to sponsor students to pay for
their education it's about creating a
context a lab context where we think
about what humanist research humanistic
research means in a way that prepares
kids for a range of job students for a
range of jobs but also teaches you modes
of thought that involve making and
thinking together so I think that's part
part of what I was satisfied about
creating at MIT uh through the
comparative media studies program and
part of what I'm trying to figure out
how to do in the USC context through the
anenberg Innovation lab some of the
other kinds of projects that I've been
invested in there thank
you hi Ro Alejandra Lopez uh CMS Alum I
want to first of all thank you Henry for
your talk
I wanted to ask you you mentioned before
the importance of looking into industry
and you know CMS is very much structured
in a way that acknowledges the
importance of looking at both Academia
and Industry when looking at these
issues around media I wanted to ask you
what your opinion is around the public
sector given that the acknowledgement
of agency the agency of people in
industry is relatively recent whereas in
a lot of public sect sector in nonprofit
in community
organizations process and agency
empowerment of people has been kind of
at the Forefront and a lot of the
concepts that you work with are would be
readily accepted and and adapted to
allow for Community media and a lot of
these different types of uh Dynamics so
can you speak a little bit about how you
see the future of these types of of
areas of study in the public
sector I mean I when when I say 60%
40% of our student the vision was 40% of
students go get phds and go into
Academia and 60% or elsewhere I
certainly think elsewhere includes the
public sector I certainly and we've seen
our students go into AR Cur readerships
policy think tanks uh you know nonprofit
organizations educational reform groups
so forth so I think there's nothing
intrinsic the CMS which says you're
going to go into a a corporate media job
I think we probably have done less to
theorize that that because it's less
there's less critique of that work right
in the sense that we I once we launched
CMS I found myself continually having to
justify what it means for humanities to
have a conversation with industry in a
way that we don't get questions about
what is it mean for humanistic trained
people to go into nonprofit
organizations we should be theorizing it
more deeply but CMS for the first 10
years at least and probably still was
fighting for its existence and fighting
to defend its model for what media
studies education could look like and a
lot of that was over where does our
money come from and who are we beholding
to if we accept checks from different
groups and from the beginning the goal
was to have a mixed portfolio that
include money from industry because
that's where the money is like the
that's you rob banks because that's
where the money is but you also uh you
know you also we we were involved with
foundations like the MacArthur
Foundation and the Knight foundation and
the marle foundation and that we wor
that Spencer we worked with and we were
involved with governments like the
Singapore media development Authority so
I think the vision was to prepare
students for all of those directions and
I think more than that what I was hoping
we would do is by training people from
those different are those different
career goals side by side was build a
network that spanned across things that
are siloed in everyday life that it
created a fluidity of conversation
between the the business Community the
jour IST world the art World education
world the public policy world that those
people should be talking to each other
that what they say about business school
whether it's Sloan or the other place up
the river uh is um you know is that you
the most valuable thing is that the the
contact list you get of your classmates
as you go forward in your career and I
think what's happened with CMS is we've
got people who are pursuing many
different careers and are able to
connect with each other in ways that are
not on the maps that are not channeled
by The Silo structure that takes place
one learning from one of the ways one
can see that embodied is in the median
transition conferences which were
intentionally uh uh uh targeted uh not
only across academic disciplines but
were intended to include people from
business and and and the public sector
when those conferences have been
successful I think most of them have
been very successful the conversation
has been as Henry describes across
borders that are usually not so easily
crossed I hope I I haven't fully
answered your question because I haven't
fully theorized what that relationship
to the nonprofit sector looks like but I
I I I would encourage others to think
deeply about what that how we might
understand that relationship because
nonprofits always fall through the
cracks you know I I reminded of of Yi
bink's wealth of networks book which I
read just after convergence culture went
to press in which he sort of argued
against seeing a world where there's
commercial and amateur media producers
and focusing on a world where they're
producers of many different motives
including nonprofits educational
institutions political activist groups
governmental agencies religious agencies
and so forth I tried very hard with
spreadable media to make sure we touched
on all of those different dimensions of
media because I think we we need that
more diverse picture of what the media
scape looks
like thank you
question hi Henry hi my name is Derek
Breen I'm a designer on the star logo
team here and I also do a curriculum
development for star logo and scratch
when I work with young students and
varying age teachers with both scratch
and star logo I'm often found myself
reflecting back on the book Diamond age
um so where Neil Stevenson takes sort of
The Prince and poer approach of having a
young girl and a and a I'm sorry a
street archin and basically a princess
Bill Gates's daughter and gives them
each the same piece of technology and
sees the course of their lives I guess
I'm asking if you could talk a bit about
how you've reflected on ways that we
have or haven't nurtured
storytelling while we've been expanding
the technological possibilities or the
the access to different mediums through
these past 20 30 years
yeah I think storytelling may be the
most important Civic skill of our time I
and I see story you know as I said we
did a webinar series for MacArthur in
January where we brought together 20
young activists from everything from the
Occupy Movement to Anonymous to the
dreamers to environmental activism to
Iraq veterans against the war all to
people sex sex worker people against
sexual violence and on behalf of sex
work workers in India the invisible
children all of these organizations
which have achieve risen and fallen off
their capacity to create compelling
stories that tell about the world that
Force us to rethink who we are and what
our ethical commitments are and
commitments for
change I'm not you know I then this is
the heart of what I call media literacy
it's not just critical cons consumption
it's not just critical production it's
critical participation of which the
ability to articulate your story and
dialogue with other people is an
important part of that I think there's
storytelling Traditions everywhere I
think you know you it's not that
storytelling per se is not about
educational access that you know the
poorest of the poor have narratives that
they tell that make sense of economic
inequalities structural constraints the
other things that they're struggling
with in their lives that the oral
tradition lives in the black church in
Mexico talk radio and any number of
other kinds of communities of of divers
diverse communities Across America the
ability to create media that transmits
that story and the understanding of how
stories circulate in the network Society
is something that's unevenly distributed
across all groups and there's a report
that the good participation team at
Harvard that Howard Howard Gardner heads
uh is Carri James is leading is really
looking at different political practices
in a network society that involve forms
of participation and what robust and
weaker versions of those are and how
those skills and practices are
distributed across the population so
it's not do people participate it's do
some groups tend to participate in a way
that show has a robust understanding of
not just the technology but the
communities the the the social dynamics
of participation and are others
participating in a relatively trivial
way grabbing information off Wikipedia
you know searching something on Google
without going very deep into and trivial
is the wrong word there but relatively
simple way um it can be very profound in
and of itself and I think that's that's
something we lose track of but there are
different degrees of sophistication and
knowledge and skill involved in these
different layers and we need to have a
deeper understanding of how those are
distributed I I would think stories are
so fundamental to human beings that we
by and large tell stories at every level
of society and every segment of the
population but how to tell stories in a
network Society may be something that
very few people fully understand and
where we can do more to Foster the
critical skills that allow these voices
to be heard effectively at all levels of
the society thank
you they've actually been waiting a
longer you've been waiting longer come
no no let's let's stay with the people
we'll go on to this side next all right
go I want to I want to answer as many
questions as I as we can I will try to
be briefer maybe but uh so I'm Yuka I'm
a visiting student from Japan and I'm
afraid my question is a little bit off
the point from today's talk but I'm
curious about media convergence and so
some like while some media like Facebook
and Twitter becomes Global um but I I I
think like some media like especially
for fun Community is still separated
depending on language or ethnicity or
something so I wonder if the or the
media or social networking service is
heading for the convergence or are they
still remain like segregated depending
on the language or Nation are they
headed for convergence or will they
continue to be disaggregated depending
on the that's an interesting question I
mean if you know if there so this is a
qu that stake here is the question of
whether a network Society is necessarily
a global Society I think it's very
clearly transnational in that some
centers of cultural creation around the
world are interfacing with each other in
a more robust way than ever before right
but language is a key op key factor in
that so those that speak English
language are connected with each other
those that speak Spanish or maybe
connected with each other more deeply
those that come out of a Chinese
diaspora are probably connected to each
other but how do we bridge that and
Ethan Zucker man's new book uh has a lot
to say about that question and it's one
that I I'm still struggling with in my
own my own thinking it's deeper than
language though and I think um which is
to say that part of what I'm interested
in exploring right now is what forms
participation takes in different
cultural economic and political
Traditions uh so with social media is
obviously going to operate differently
in different social context that's sort
of a given we may use it and different
groups may use it different ways it's
used but in the deeper sense of what's
at stake is not Twitter but
participation how do we understand what
participation means in Latin America as
or in Eastern Europe or in Africa as
compared to the United States that's a
core question on my blog recently I
featured a series of posts by polish
Scholars describing how popular culture
and participatory culture has taken
shape in Poland after the fall of
Communism and issues around
collectivity uh are crucial for for a
country that was forced into
collectivities and now is struggling to
figure out how to form new social
structures that have mutuality and
reciprocity but are not governed by the
kinds of categories by which Communism
organized things or if we're looking at
China the the ways in which the two
economies and the one child policy and
other things that are going on there
have consequences for how people are
using social media how people are
forming social connections to each other
there's so much work got to be done and
even the scholarship that's produced is
blocked by the language barriers that
you're talking about so something is
basic as I know there's incredible work
on otaku culture going on in Japan U
seean out there but um very little of
that has been translated into English
and as someone who spent a lot of my
life studying fandom I get Snippets of
things removed from Context without
understanding the larger debate and
really am eager to engage with that work
but it is very very difficult to do
without the language skills that Connect
English and Japanese together um and and
I so we may have more opportunities than
ever before but it doesn't mean we know
how to overcome some classic problems
that make glob exchange really viable or
even transnational exchange really
viable and so I you know I there
something I struggle with I'm not I far
I'm trying to become more Global myself
but I'm not I Far From Success role
model for anyone to follow in that
regard over
here hi my name is Jesse uh first year
CMS grad student um so early on in your
talk you mentioned that you had the
feeling of being beaten up on the
subject of violence in video games and I
was wondering if you would mind speaking
a bit about uh kind of engaging in a
public sector the the idea of um media
effects more generally and maybe with
avoiding The Quagmire that is the
violence and video games debate just
talking about recommendations on how to
engage with that subject or maybe coming
to the aid of uh fans Gamers or any
subculture who's kind of demonized
through use of a certain type of media
sure uh I mean then this is something
that I've struggled with in a different
way since coming to USC because I'm now
on a program where some of the leading
media effect scholars in in the world
are my colleagues that I sit across from
at faculty meetings and it's helped me
to focus more on the fact that my qu is
not per se with media effects as a
research tradition but the way media
effects research gets deployed in public
conversations the ways in which it Jews
the shut down discussions about the
value and meaning of cultural experience
rather than to deepen them the ways in
which media effect Scholars often have
not taken responsibility publicly for
the ways in which their research has
been taken up and used by policy makers
and politicians troubles me a great deal
the ways in which in when I go to
Washington I'd be sat on one table and
Stacy Smith my USC colleague would be
sat on an opposite table when in fact we
probably agree on 75 or 80% of the
topics and the interesting stuff would
come if we could establish that common
ground and then drill down on the 20%
where there is really substantive Suson
and disagreement but that's never going
to happen that that that what Washington
does to research is to bifurcate it into
two parties in much the same way that
itself is structured around two parties
and the finding the middle ground
finding the ways those things come
together is not in anyone's interest so
if I have a quarrel with the media
effects tradition it's the way it's
allowed itself to be taken up and not be
critical about the process that's going
on what would be a concrete example of
what you mean about the way it's been
appropriated as against what the well I
think if you look at some behaviorist
say which I am much more dubious about
this well I I mean I'm I'm not saying
that I I let me separate out so when
Edward constein did research that talked
about porn and sexual violence when that
stuff was taken up by Andrea dworin and
Katherine McKinnon as a legislative
agenda which simplified and reduced the
findings that he had made he publicly
spoke out against the use of his
research in ways that he felt distorted
its finding when media violence research
has been used in public policy debates
in this country the Craig Andersons
remain deadly silent on the subject of
how their work is being done and it's
not that I totally agree with Craig
Anderson it's that I think his work is
more subtle than the Public Presentation
of it is so if Craig Anderson says that
video games are one risk factor among
many that might result in young people
becoming more aggressive and it's
translated into the causal connections
between video games and real world
violence are undeniable by a public
Advocate I think he should speak out
that those are not the same statement
what whatever that those are very
different arguments that and to remain
silent in terms of that and not to
engage critically with that use of your
your stuff is not scientifically
responsible if if you're going to say
you're a scientist and you don't want to
be involved in partisan politics I get
it but a scientist whose work was
fundamentally distorted let's think
about Carrie Emanuel here at MIT in
terms of the area of climate research
and storms the car emanu is who was
deeply apolitical in his research
eventually is forced to speak out about
some of the claims that are being made
in his on behalf of his research in a
way that I think is what a responsible
scientist does and I don't think the
media effects people working in violence
have been prepared to do that and I
think that has an enormous effect on
public policy because in Washington
people who can claim to be scientists
get heard differently than people who
claim to be humanists and so the fact
that we can criticize and talk about the
cultural role and the meaning and
transgression and all kinds of words
that describe how this stuff can be used
in ways that are meaningful will be
trumped by research that claims
scientific Authority and what we're
being trumped by is not the research
itself where I have methodological
criticisms and I don't always agree with
the conclusions but the way that
research has been deployed so the how do
we find a voice to Advocate effectively
against that I think is a really
interesting challenge I think we've made
ground on the games and violence debate
I think G games as a and what I wanted
to do there was first of all Challenge
fight against censorship of games and
regulation of content not to defend what
games are doing but to prevent us from
imposing constraints that would prevent
games from growing and maturing as a
medium that could do more than they were
currently achieving and the analogy I
would draw as to the comic book code in
the 1950s where wor them attack on comic
books results in regul self-regulation
that stunted the growth of comics as a
medium about 15 years and dramatically
decreased the readership of comics and
its cultural significance if games were
going to ever achieve something more
than being shooting galleries then what
we needed to do was not to silence them
but to push them to take greater
creative responsibility over the choices
they were making so that's battle one
and battle two was as long that that the
government was never going to take
regulatory aim at the media industry but
the effect of government hearings on
media violence was to stigmatize Gamers
and schools who were being punished for
playing games who were being punished
for adopting ident gamer identities at
school and were at risk from other
regulatory structures other repressive
structures in their society so the only
way to protect those kids I felt was to
challenge first of all that whether we
should even be having government
authorities where there's no legislation
being proposed whether the hearings are
even legitimate if there is no clear
path to legislation should our
legislature investigating things uh when
the whole goal is to intimidate people
into self-regulation is that an
acceptable goal for governmental action
that's to me is a really interesting
question but beyond that the question
the conclusion that simply links people
who are stigmatized through Outsiders to
for to claims about violence and
aggression that are
unfounded um and then to St use that as
a stepping stone in which to challenge
the industry to to make more interesting
games and that's where I as I talked
earlier about the fact that I think
games and content have largely been
stagnant have not explored the
potentials eye and other people thought
were there to the degree to which
they've deepened uh what the potential
of that Medium could be and yeah around
the edges I see interesting indie games
that are exploring that space I don't
mean they haven't done it at all but I
mean the commercial games industry has
not been forced so I was hoping to be in
a world where we could talk by this
point about games the way we talk about
Morton Scorsese or Quinton tarantina we
can have a debate about the Ro of
violence in their work but we don't have
a debate about the fact that there that
it has artistic Merit and social
significance I don't know that I can
have a debate about whatever rockstar I
released this year that goes to that
level of depth because I think that
they've continue to exploit the
controversy as for their commercial
interest rather than rise above it and
try to explore the me what the medium
could do on a deeper
way thank you
Sasha hi uh Sasha castanza chak uh
faculty in
cmsw
um so I was really excited to hear about
the project that you're working on with
students at USC the B any media uh
necessary um it definitely resonates
with uh the framework that I've used
around trans media quote you extensively
and but but in the last couple years as
I've looked at this uh process of you
know so social movement actors have
always used every media that they have
access to uh to you know uh tell their
stories amplify their voices and gain
adherence um in the context of moving
that type of activity online uh in the
midst of the Snowden uh Revelations and
the conversation about uh surveillance
not only from private actors but also
from the state and also peer-to-peer
surveillance I am trying to rethink that
argument and I wonder you know sort of
invoking James Scott we might say that
the hidden transcripts that social
movements have previously produced and
circulated cultural materials through uh
known networks now that it's moved
online it's become visible and it's a
tool that's uh easily accessed by uh
those who would repress the movements
and so I wonder what
contribution uh you know media Scholars
who are attuned to the complexity of
participatory culture as a as a space
for politics you know we have to make
both in public conversation but also
specifically to those who are within
industry uh who will need to take
stances about how they're going to
relate to uh you know State agents
making requests and uh every well
everything from the level of the uh how
they develop and deploy the technical
protocols that govern how easy or
difficult it will be uh for that to
happen how their business models are
structured and the legal responses that
they'll make to uh to state agents who
want them to hand over
the the data so they can repress the
movements so I wonder what what you
think about that new wrinkle uh it's it
is it's I'm not even I'm not sure it's
even a new wrinkle but it is a wrinkle
one has to Grapple with when you talk
about participatory politics you're
absolutely right and identifying some of
the crisis points there so we you know
one of the things that many things
frustrated me about Malcolm gladwell's
piece uh about Twitter revolutions um
one is what you alluded to the fact that
previous that he's I call it Compares a
platform with a movement so the
comparison ought to be with the
telephone revolution of the 1950s and
60s I we of have a slide I often sh of
King talking on the telephone and
knowing that the telephone was pretty
crucial for organizing that but we know
we would never reduce the Civil Rights
Movement to the telephone and we should
never reduce contemporary media media
activism to Twitter or any other
platform that it is precisely that it
travels across media and your work on
trans media mobilization has been really
helpful to me as I think about how that
travel takes place and how different
travels takes place differently for
various groups but what we talk about is
these publics as precarious as a word we
use a lot and we talk about risk and
that's the other side of Gladwell as he
downplays the risk of digital activism
well as anyone who works on the dreamers
knows there are kids who've been
deported based on materials they put on
YouTube Twitter and Facebook which is a
significant risk and some of these kids
are going into ins headquarters cameras
attached to their bodies and announcing
they're undocumented and recording until
the cameras are confiscated or they're
tweeting on the plane as they're being
thrown out of the country rather than
going quietly into the night and those
are behaviors that involve considerable
amount of risk and surveillance is one
of those kinds of risks so Sangita shovo
on our team has been really have issued
a white paper about the American Muslim
experience post 911 and the paradoxes of
struggling to use gain visibility in
order to challenge negative
representations of their culture and yet
being more subject to surveillance at
all levels the more deeply they get
involved in in that form of media
expression the more public they become
the more exposed they become and more
exposed they become to risk and for them
that can be everything from governmental
surveillance and you know from the NSA
or the New York Police Department to
surveillance within their own community
and and conservative Muslims critiquing
them attacking them people attacking
finding them online and using them as
the bully boy for their hostility toward
terrorists you know that kind of attack
and so surveillance there is part of a
larger picture of all kinds of ways in
which being visible is to be exposed and
the question is how then does the
community rally to support and protect
its members as they're daring to speak
out against that and and king and the
civil rights movement of 50 and 60s had
practices in place to prepare them so
that you know if you see the footage of
the Freedom Writers in the north being
trained to go to the South to sit at
lunch counters and face that the amount
of training in how to withstand abuse
and preserve nonviolence that those
students went through is very different
from the kind of lack of structures you
see for some of the undocumented youth
going to ins headquarters with webcams a
false sense of security in some cases
that uh the they're going to be
protected by the web that I don't think
will protect them as deeply and as
profoundly as the kind of organizational
structures the previous generations had
and so I'm I worry about do we see the
digital as a sub and visibility on the
web as a substitute for sign some of the
community building activities that other
Generations did in addition to making
sure that the television cameras of CBS
ABC and NBC was Tor T turned to face
them you know what uh in in an email to
me uh Henry noted that one of the
announcements about his event uh had the
wrong time on it it said am instead of
PM and he quietly remarked that of
course he was perfectly capable of
beginning at 7:30 a.m. and continuing
through 11: p.m. uh and you can see that
that's surely true I want to thank Henry
and thank the
audience